citizens of the reject Nation it is time
to make it to our third part of the
Final Destination it's Final Destination
three where are we going we're gonna go
on the roller coaster of Love Today
roller coaster okay you predicted
Highway to Hell I'm predicting roller
coaster of love let's see if that's true
I see roller coaster I think it's fun
family movie probably gonna be their
first comedy in the franchise a first
comedy in these past two have been
hilarious yeah all the physical comedy
that you told me would be there you guys
like these movies as much as we do and
you like that we're doing these
reactions don't forget to like this
video subscribe all that good stuff also
if you want to get the full length
Reaction watch along then make sure you
can sync up with us if you go to
patreon.com the real rejects Greg and
John are covering several shows
exclusively over there with reaction
highlights and watch alongs included
those are all the super
checks are oh yeah oh yeah the way that
you are rubber chickening your neck
right now I didn't stretch here we go I
want her to wish your grandma a happy
birthday it's my Grammy's 96th birthday
she's going there immediately after this
yeah I am so she thought she should get
a horror show and right before going to
see her grandparents she wanted cotton
pajamas oh
he's so sweet so that's exactly what
she'll get happy birthday okay but did
you hear my third time's a charm
reference like that was a great
transition that you I might have been so
focused on making sure I got my thing in
there that I didn't quite but good job
because I found this in three so third
time's a charm now
[Music]
guess who's back
crack it rocks air pack tell a friend
you tell all your friends all your
friends tweet it out recommend this
video perhaps
you're stoked we're at the theme park
theme park let's go roll the coaster
[Music]
this is gonna cool intro this is way
more horror like I feel like this is it
vibes
the tarot cards
[Music]
Mary Elizabeth Winstead is in this I
love her
[Music]
so you directed this because this looks
really good bright colors different more
pup
[Music]
oh boy the anxiety of a theme park I
think it's a carnival yeah definitely
James Wong
[Music]
oh James won co-wrote it cool
James long is back to direct it so he
did all three of these so far he did the
first one and and he didn't do the
second one oh
I love these rides they tell you to
scream on the way up to tighten your
stomach so it doesn't drop as much
that is a scary shot
[Applause]
kid on the right what is his name he's
Texas long bottom or whatever that guy's
name very very famous we are gonna get
annihilated for that
[Music]
what do you see
no way hot die yeah die and to feel how
that would be to crash and burn like
that
oh what TV show is it Dawson's Creek or
what he who is it yeah he looks like
he's played a really nice guy before or
a douchebag 7th Heaven no he's won one
of those shows we watched growing up oh
what doesn't kill you makes you stronger
man never heard that one before yeah
I love how the main characters are
always in the situations where they're
with their friends and it's the most
terrifying situation beforehand for them
so this can be a carnival right
carnivals don't have roller coasters
like that it's a movie Carnival come on
it's not even mine Kevin is the
yearbooks
upskirting women is a big No-No these
are for the yearbook I doubt it if a
shot of Stacy kobiatch is camel to make
it in there
I buy two
we got the Bros back can you make me
crazy I'm breaking up with him
get it girl
aha you don't need no man now that's
right there that'll sell some yearbooks
One Tree Hill no no he does look
familiar I think he's in another horror
movie I love the 2000s songs out
same as the exact things uh the last two
focusing on weird images
oh my God I do miss carnivals haven't
been to one in a long time you've got to
stop calling in a carnival though but
it's a carnival how is it a carnival
like what about the pier what do you
call the Santa Monica Pier
I
back off
that's so fair
here we go
oh my God is here token black guy
that's what I'm talking about
oh no
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh
no oh no
I thought it was going to decapitate
me transcending became one with you say
no no
there it is awesome there it is stop the
jams
look at the nipples on that dear devil
this is a really nice Carnival this is a
carnival the prizes and or it could be
the pier they say the real fear with
these rides comes from the feeling of
having no control so dude another horror
movie you made me watch what movie if
the newspaper
in the family
and they're dead that was Ethan Hawk
phone
have you ever seen that no exit after
Turn Style yeah something along those
lines okay so which of your her friends
do you think are gonna die first ooh
probably her best friend the girl who's
gonna dump the dude yeah
you see I think James Wong is is a much
better composer with his frames like
there's much more sharp Direction
roller coaster is just Elemental physics
a conversion of potential energy to
kinetic energy yeah odds are like one in
250 million of dying in a roller coaster
oh my God are you ever dead you're more
likely to die driving to an amusement
park than dying at one that's true those
are some amusement parks amusement park
is an amusement park damn it would you
tell me back off
[Music]
a guy from the other horror movie you
made me watch The Descent now that it
was all women I like this Frankie cheats
is old school ladies
what's that oh well it'd be my honor
oh oh
I hated that this guy is a repulsive I
can't sit in the front I cannot see the
tracks oh freak oh Carol's in the back
with you right babe because we're girls
oh no whoever sits with her is going to
live whoever doesn't is gonna die all
right you know what we'll just settle
this like real man how about that call
it heads
[__] they found out he died in the
newspaper
I won't figure it out later
hey just do me a favor keep an eye on
her okay she's just kind of freaked out
oh cool yeah I have no idea
that's why he's going back because he's
the most famous one okay so can't kill
him yeah in the movie
that's a devil number baby devil
cool shot here we go hey Jay keep your
hands to yourself man I'm serious
payback's a [__] God damn you now I'm
like trying to figure out oh no what's
happening what's happening he sneaks in
now
get in the back
oh now they're gonna live or are we
gonna see the death thing happen and
then they never get on
hey
how'd you guys get in here come on you
too that's an interesting detail about
those little kids what do you think that
has to do with it yeah I'm curious too
what's up man I'm good
oh
yes it was dripping blood it looks like
it how do you do on roller coasters I
used to be great now I'm terrible
loser what
I'm just kidding is this this is gonna
be an enjoyable reaction
I'm my chest just hurts now whenever I'm
on a roller coaster I get it oh ew
ew
[Music]
[Applause]
maybe once we get back to this if they
don't get on the kids do get to stay on
or something and then the kids die I
don't know that was a really interesting
[Applause]
[Music]
details are acting like this is the
roller coaster of the century it's
exciting everyone's like this is the
most exact thing ever every time I've
been in a roller coaster we're just like
all right let's just go my mom used to
put cardboard in my shoes so I'd be tall
enough to ride the rides I wonder how
safe that was
horrified
this looks just like Colossus or Goliath
yeah I wonder where they shot this or
also you wonder how many times they had
to shoot these scenes I know right
[Music]
[Applause]
cool
this is a really well captured roller
coaster scene
a good time
they could be just setting us up right
now yeah they just get off the road
oh
the Pervert cost them
that is so scary yeah that is terrifying
that is scary
Goosebumps
so cows are gonna stop
oh Jesus
oh no oh no that is so scary they do a
great job of taking what are some
people's biggest fears and making them
the beginning of their movies yeah
oh my God he's holding on grab him grab
him
oh no his legs
[Music]
was this all because of the camera or
there was like 80 things that happened
yeah there's the pipe bursting too
[Music]
oh Jesus
oh my God
[Music]
I'll be rocking
whoa they really hung those people there
how many Rockets smart
oh no that is so scary
[Music]
sit down sit down
there we go okay read oh well I'll just
I'll put in my pocket yeah
all right let's do this wait what are
you you know that honestly might have
been the scariest one to me yeah because
it's so many people's irrational fear
[Music]
I am so glad they got married Elizabeth
Winstead she is such a great actress
yeah she's really good
my head
the tracks collapse the rollercoaster no
she was just a little upset before man
please can you please control that [__]
oh damn damn dude unless he just trying
to get some [__] attention you know
what you're a real piece of [__] Louis
[__] you damn it [__] you oh great the
franchise is full of the most
insensitive people
dude let me off I gotta make sure she's
okay oh this poor guy let's go bummer
not for long that's sad this is what you
get for not sitting with your girlfriend
yeah
[Music]
call your mother they're about to watch
everybody start falling
wow good one damn this is good franchise
yeah that's what I told you I know and I
agreed that's what I said and then you
also said it and then I said it again
we're on the same page
I have a feeling I'm gonna connect a
little bit more to these characters yeah
I'm already in on them I really cared
about that situation when he he couldn't
get off of the roller coaster
did it say how long after this is not
yet oh he's in the locker I'm telling
you he was in the newspaper I didn't
believe you we'll look it up later
[Music]
oh come on give me the exposition it's
been six months
it wasn't for you and Jay being friends
me and Carrie being friends
we wouldn't have even hung out but now
you're gonna be lovers wow that's cold
you better get it
we're ready for graduation tonight we're
going to the tanning salon after this
and we are so totally cool if you want
to come with oh you know there's going
to be a 10 in Salon death you get stuck
in there and burned to death yes
if you're not alone oh God I appreciate
everyone trying to help okay I really do
no we tap in before okay I went online
looking for an explanation
I like him I know I like them both they
really have a lot of angry women in
their franchise
men write it I went on a trip to Paris
when they were boarding a kid had a
vision that the plane was gonna explode
you know in the next several months
everyone who got off that plane started
dying in weird accidents they died in
the order they would have if they stayed
on the plane
I I'm liking this the characters more do
they not know about the car accident one
too I guess not the most televised one
was the flight 180. also what did he
Google to get that has this ever
happened before yeah
that was a popular incident this one's a
story about grief
flamma ball
how can we go for like a tune-up I just
want to make sure that we look our best
yeah you know for all those kids that
died that night we'll never get a
graduation
have you ever gone on a tanning bed no
no have you
way too many times when I was a kid
they're actually very relaxing I guess
unless they explode well watch this
movie let's see what happens
bracelet that grandma left me in her
will Julie
you're not really mad with each other I
could use some help
yeah I can't talk
I love it you're all I have left
maybe you could come stay with me for
what
you know I will
oh yes yes sister
keep this now
and
I'll get it when I come see you I forget
was she on the ride I know she was
questioning that right now too I can
remember can I use a school camera for
graduation tonight actually the battery
is pretty low so why don't you go get
ready and I'll recharge it a bit
the upskirting
not drinks in the room this time okay
very 2000s
what he's gonna get stuck outside and
he's not gonna be able to help them
I am really enjoying the refinement
aspects of the execution of this
[Music]
no don't go above 12 minutes honey what
a horrible thing to have happen and I
don't even know what happened yet
what what is gonna happen he's gonna not
be able to open the door it's gonna get
stuck and they're gonna be stuck in the
machines and they can't get them out and
they're gonna like burn to death at
least one of them maybe we'll see
what does you see
what I don't know what that means she
literally touched it I still don't know
what it was dude you said he said no
drinks if you spill that [__] we're
gonna have to clean it up like last time
maybe it's just we called her from
machines or whatever a few degrees won't
hurt
I've never been into a salon with two in
one room
oh great it's so bad for you kids will
be kids teens will be teens Greg
Potter
I feel like there's gonna be some like
insane domino effect
yet again
[Music]
those two interesting things I think
there's interesting things in this
franchise for sure well booby never
heard anything sometimes I just can't
take my eyes off the screen you know
because you got you can't miss anything
I just can't miss any detail you never
know what's gonna happen you just gotta
look maybe we should rewind it
oh this is going to be disturbing I can
really feel this
[Music]
let the fun begin oh no
their plate is off
here
yeah
I hate you you're looking at one yeah I
said it I was looking at something else
on screen okay you got Highway to Hell I
got roller coaster of Love wow you
really called it
does that mean that we are predicting
the future and therefore
are we gonna have something happens if
the producer's still watching this can
you put us in Final Destination six
please and thank you thank you
[Music]
oh no this is gonna be so gross oh I
oh no
yeah
with the goggles too it's creepy this is
a really smart move of theirs of the of
the movie not the girls I think it's a
great combination of both whoa cool shot
sorry the battery's totally dead
camera's not working sorry
Julie I need a minute okay take
Grandma's necklace back
[Music]
I just gotta call him
we're the acid Player rock goes for love
later in the movies
that's pretty gnarly that is you said it
too hot in here
[Music]
oh
okay oh no
death you genius this is Wendy give me a
call whenever you guys are done and
thanks again for the invite
stay calm sorry I was too late
you can cool your body down with
meditation
[Music]
oh no
you can't slide out of there
Greg
oh God
[Music]
they're not gonna look good for
graduation
[Music]
that was whoa great match cut you see
that damn that was
horrifying I know oh my God Greg
the end of the nudity yes that was the
sad part
we are all equal
in death's eyes they just like dress the
same everywhere they go all of us how
can you say that shut up
dude I think it's true Charlie Manson
minute to 70. Osama let's go still
kicking pimps nope we got him got his
ass
these two girls who never done [__] to
anybody they don't get to make it to 18.
yeah
Fine Mary Elizabeth Winston wants to get
off the ride says she's a [__] who
wants attention guy freaks out at a
funeral yeah come on bro let's go this
is so my fault
seeing women is nothing but fun bags
buy the scene there
whatever Humanity
they wouldn't have felt the pressure to
look so good
and press Franklin cheeks she looks like
Jennifer Love Hewitt be proud of your
ability to make everything that happens
somehow a story about you
oh my God
that was great that was so funny
yeah man I think just James really knows
how to capture the colors of movies man
this looks so good hey if you ever have
to come to my funeral and bring me a PSP
or something at least I have something
to do then hello
do you think they're gonna fall in love
we haven't had that happen full blown
yet it'd be a little disrespectful huh I
don't know man works in mysterious ways
I didn't want to upset anyone by being
there and I wondered if maybe here I
could feel Chase
Spirit or presence if there's any place
that makes you feel like there's no life
after death
huh yeah I haven't felt Carey's spirit
either
I tried
your conversation
there's just to get me on the ride he
said your fear
is from a sense of having no control
and I felt that fear since the moment he
said
it's like a presence
like a living thing
always with me remember Carrie was gonna
break up with him yeah yeah he hasn't
even she hasn't even mentioned that yeah
she will in a mean moment it's cold
and terrifying
trippy so trying to think about the
roller coaster who should be next then
the two girls and then the guy who was
videotaping them the one who just tried
to kiss yeah yeah probably although he
took the he took her their spaces yeah
so really would they be next they were
last no but remember originally they
were behind the two girls and then the
guy jumped in front of them and took
their spaces I don't remember well
enough yeah to videotape them and that's
when they moved to the back where the
kids were the photographic plate was
broken causing a line that can't be
removed exactly where he was shot
what
look
see the shadow well what do these
pictures have to do with us this
occurred one year to the day of the
flight 180 says Hey part two but you
can't believe every weird thing out
there because you're desperate for an
answer I took these
I don't get what you see
I'm totally missing whatever it is it's
like an image of it that's like a line
these 180 degrees
so just a line oh I think is what she's
saying what's Frankie's picture look
like it's right here
so
[Applause]
sorry I think death feels more like a
haunting looming presence in this one
too
good advertisement this is donkeys yeah
well this is obvious he's falling off a
ladder a rope ladder though maybe he
might hang oh okay so in the pictures
there's it alludes to how they die okay
yeah there's signs in there what like
he's gonna get crushed by a giant
SpongeBob oh
hey SpongeBob lives underwater
so sad that you know that everybody
knows that's the song what was the 180
part though aren't those usually on
those big 18 wheelers yeah yeah I don't
see it in this picture anywhere though
[Music]
all right
yeah it's because he's not gonna get
killed by the 18 wheeler you guys were
next I feel like he's about to die what
do you want
are you okay yeah we're in trouble yeah
no they're gonna get skipped over but it
is coming right now
180 180
. this guy's way too close to my truck
too [__] close man pull up
oh death is having so much fun
oh [__] get out get out there's no one
in that truck
what an insane domino effect
oh is that pervert guy
in front of them remember I told you
they were next
foreign
he's gonna die
[Applause]
kick out kick out yep yep get out
[Music]
it was perfect guy did you see him I saw
him but I don't think it was oh it was
good one so was it coming for pervert
guy or was it coming for that pervert
guy but but why then in the first movie
was it based on their original seats not
the seats that you sat in I have no idea
you know what I'm saying though yeah
we can walk to my house and then I'll
give you a ride to yours I think so
we'll be okay
you know I feel like this one is doing
the you asked me in the last video what
I wish the sequels would do and this
one's giving it to me like there's more
tension yeah and I care more yeah no I
don't care about the dots that's what
you were yeah well overall I do just
care more about everything but the
characters care more about the death yes
I agree with you yeah
okay easy
cool cool hand all right he was behind
Ashley and Ashland on the ride but there
was no ladder here you know there was no
rope nothing because this one was coming
for you guys it's better not knowing no
it's never better staying ignorant
willful ignorance is surrendering
control there's philosophy in this movie
Man
oh tell him don't tell him tell him why
would you do that because then she could
have a shot
yeah
I was gonna ask her to marry me
oh really she was gonna break up with
you
upskirt picture this picture shows how
he died all right go back to Louis the
weight looks like it's coming down on
his head this is so cool you got to
interpret photos oh that is really
awesome agreed look at these pictures of
us in there
of course
no no I don't want to see mine no but
you got to be able to if there's any way
to beat this thing
I gotta stay focused and if I look at
that picture all I'm gonna do is obsess
so you know what no I don't want to see
it weird logic would you want to see I
would want 100.
you all crack wait they're literally
like personal trainers who have died at
the gym from like weight lifting wrong
and an accident happening of course
all right
I love the game of clues in this one you
both lost people real close to you on
the way and in order to feel less guilty
or whatever seeing signs and patterns
man does this say that something would
smash on his head based on the yeah it
looked like something was going to smash
on his head so they should be on the
lookout for something smashing on his
head
but that would cut off his head enough
yeah but that's in the picture it's a
mislead right no they're just seeing
that the Bears here this is here you're
here and Alive because of her no I'm
alive because of me you don't get
Rover the black guy really doesn't
believe
talk about a vision I hope they save him
in four years from now lose a mirror
going in the second round
stop 15 Seasons
I can't get over how great the direction
is in this oh no
you think it's gonna happen yeah
stop ew stop him
it's gonna fall on his head oh no so
there's a question
no this guy's open it says open I
thought no I do Kevin baby I just win
that was like the dentist scene for me
just
why me all those people out there wanted
to have a premonition or see a ghost or
whatever I don't this one's like
existential and reflective I I like it a
lot with stereotypical ensembles getting
killed off
my head's not like through the
windshield or anything yeah crushed by a
steering wheel paled by gear shift he's
definitely gonna die in this movie just
look at the photo man yeah and then make
out with her because that's what I want
I want it to happen they're both really
good looking yeah totally got those
Planet orders yet ah it's a big no pip
Osama
setting off the alarms wow a couple of
sama references yeah I know this guy
loves referencing Osama it's the same
guy who refers
and we did have a picture of the Twin
Towers too babies yeah
oh that's cruel
oh I can't wait for you to die now
that's really cool what was in his
picture do you remember I hope it's
something horrible now
hi it's Wendy and Kevin
he's scared the [__] out of me yeah wait
till you hear what we have to tell you
you were scared before just wait till
you talk to us she'll be even more
scared isn't that exciting I'm gonna OD
on nail polish and Ian is gonna be
embarrassed to death what's happened to
the others I mean you just saw their
pictures
and that
crazy
I feel like there's some theme here
about like surrendering control or
something are you guys saying that death
is like a person
goals no awareness that it is a force in
fact in past cases if the next in line
is safe what do you think about the kids
from the beginning still though I guess
there's nothing to them no maybe they
snuck on somewhere else
hey watch those boxes
freak the guy out like that you're gonna
get him killed death is just the end of
biological function it's as simple as
that
I definitely met people like that guy
yeah me too I was just saying that what
was this pigeon being shot with the nail
gun right now well that's how he's gonna
go he was eating french toast when
Princess Diana died in Paris and then he
saw her funeral on TV and now he's dead
crazy so guess how you do something wow
death you are so clever I'm done so I
finished cutting those over so we can
get out of here okay
what do you think's Happening Here
something with a nail gun right yeah I
think the nails are gonna get him
somehow
do you not hear it falling
they've really amped up the domino
effect here
like every death has had a very crazy
order of events that led to it maybe
it's something they have to die
simultaneously if they were sitting next
to each other oh yeah yeah maybe that's
a good guess oh because perfect guy was
sitting alone
have you guys not hear any of this I
don't know
[Music]
foreign
I'm unclear on what but can't be good I
love the staging of these things what is
the writer's room like and then this
happens and then this and then this and
then they die what if the last in line
or to make the utilitarian Choice kill
themselves
[Music]
good question that's pretty much gonna
ruin any planned that's put in motion
and even better okay he's Gonna Save
I've skipped lives but is she capable of
doing that because in the last movie
they weren't the guy wasn't able to
death is always making an entrance
[Music]
[Applause]
brutal
oh she's still breathing there's a lot
there's more dread to this that was gory
I guess they don't have to die at the
same time do they believe you would you
believe me no they looked at me like I
was crazy for all we know whoever was
sitting behind there and is already dead
and we're next I think you're right I
think it's a sister do you think this is
gonna have any tie into the second one
uh I mean they mentioned it briefly the
second one one when she was first
pulling up the photos she said this
habit on the highway what I mean is like
referencing the second one how the
second one referenced the first one they
were all like a byproduct and they
mentioned the logs the situation the
Highway Scene no I get what you're
saying I'm asking if we think their
deaths are impacted by the second
movie's deaths the way the second
movie's deaths were impacted by the
first movie's deaths they were showing
uh like the highway sequence in the
second movie
yeah no I think I don't think they're
gonna do that you don't know
Daniel thing and I could really use my
goodness
I think it's how she's gonna find out
her sister's dead you think the somehow
the brace is going to lead to her death
no I think it's gonna be left over she
knows it was her sister who died because
the rest of her body's so mangled but
she sees the bracelet all right all
right I'm not sure I like your guesses I
like where you're at I like the way you
think
does she see the bracelet
yeah man it's the bracelet ah dude yeah
you did good you're doing good this
thing oh a lot of guesses right I don't
know I'm kind of a genius yeah kind of
do you remember Julie being on the
roller coaster what your sister no Amber
or Perry were probably with her so
they're next
I'm here now working security did we
know he did that I know and yours is the
picture that I took when I flashed the
camera in your face it's all out of
focus and over
the firework went off my face
you gotta clear up
here we go
[Music]
it's all did you ever have to do the
Rube Goldberg projects in school no I
wasn't as talented as you you'd set like
a domino and it would hit to a string
and the string would go to or whatever
like all the yeah yeah this is that this
is all about how death operates
[Applause]
foreign
picture other than her bracelet a hand
sweet
you guys are tools get lost Mary and
Pippin
oh wait wait maybe Julie lent her
bracelet to a friend I don't know
middle finger horse damn
[Music]
ah bummer
it's not over it's not over
foreign
[Music]
yeah cut that string is that a real
sword yeah
I love him I know he's about to die you
have to tell me to tell me who was
sitting next to you on the roller
coaster
oh now the the horse is about to kill
one of her friends nobody
yeah there's nobody sitting next to her
no she's about to get
oh
[Music]
together Kevin yeah go get Kevin put it
together
hick alone would have killed him
[Music]
you should pull them out yeah I know but
now it's her I saved my life
something McKinley let's see that horse
kick alone it is about McKinley it's
about the guy he's McKinley his name is
McKinley okay
early on he said I can't believe my
name's the same name as the high school
oh yeah that's right get the [__] out of
here McKinley hey I'm just celebrating
our towns tricentennial oh that's right
because he believes to kill her yeah
yeah yeah
for me it is awful I'm not dying they
say it saved you man
now if if it skips her it goes back to
him right
oh this Fool's gonna think he's an
immortal if it skips you it will go
right back around it's you it's you
Wendy
[Music]
oh
they didn't see the movies we saw so
they don't know that it circles back
they don't know the rules
oh damn the sending's a little bit more
akin to the first one
[Music]
blurry face what does blurry face mean
that's what was next to her and then
this was just blurry
180. this could be the first time our
lead character dies to close out the
movie I don't think so but could be
[Music]
the next stop
this is his here
what is going to be the domino effect
with this candy bar
[__] like yo coming through
oh she's gonna get off and they don't
that's gonna be oh her sister knows her
sister I knew it didn't I say that damn
you are you are nailing this one you
really are finally getting credit where
credit is due Emma's gonna cause your
death you intervened and it skipped us
why does death wait so long five months
to make them feel comfortable hey guys
Julie
he's on the train damn it
oh goodness
claim what's yours death how many of
them are gonna make it one two or three
none none none claim death yeah I think
this might be the first time they all
die
Julie's definitely ooh claim
or is this another vision
oh Jesus
oh damn I guess it's just really
happening I was wondering if it was
another like premonition that would have
been wild because then they would have
had to do this
foreign
ER but everybody you love is dead
what a train
it was a vision
okay
something wrong they don't have time to
get off though yeah what do you do
[Music]
it's not working
they're gonna just end it yeah oh spooky
spooky I got nipple chills at that
ending there yeah that was wild like
actual Goosebumps everywhere I I have to
have to know Ryan Merriman now that's
the first thing we're gonna take care of
okay no but it wasn't him that was the
guy that was in the other movie I I need
to I need to do my due diligence right
now you talk about the movie I have to
do my due diligence you're gonna okay
well because because for two reasons
everyone wants the newspaper movie and
number two devil's voice was Tony Todd
oh yeah good cat yeah yeah yeah really
good catch we gotta get our Tony in
there oh
um well what's your um my um did you
love it I like that one a lot most
it might be there okay again there are
things about the other ones I preferred
so you all of them are kind of even
because of that I I think that this one
is the better
uh
okay all right before I get the
comparisons out of the way I really
liked uh Mary Elizabeth Winstead a lot I
love the main guy and I thought this one
did the things that I was wanting it to
actually do when you asked but I didn't
think they would just because I was like
ah we're in SQL territory now where they
run a lot of tension it was more
reflective in between scenes like there
was actual tension when there wasn't
scary stuff happening and the two main
characters at least I thought were a
markedly better Improvement than the the
prior film
the the first one is probably still the
best mood in me but I love the look of
this film a lot I thought this film
looked great
I was more connected with the with the
couple main characters though I was too
but not not necessarily in the first one
but then the second one yes Brian
merryman was the guy in um lack of the
Irish and smart house he did the d-coms
that's why I know him
what movie did was there a newspaper
that you watched I gotta find that but I
don't think did you not see any of those
decoms no what's a decom Disney Channel
original movie oh I didn't have Disney
Channel that was a dude like none of
those cheetah sisters or like my High
School Musical yeah I didn't have to
pass my time but okay well they were big
like I remember watching him that's
where I I was like oh that younger thing
okay so that was that and this other guy
Jesse Moss let's see oh Tucker and Dale
Versus Evil He's the bad guy yes
that's a comedy you call it a horror
film I was like what's horror movie are
you talking about it's a hard comedy
yeah okay I guess promotion yeah I
couldn't remember the name of it yes but
I was right yeah you were he was the bad
guy I couldn't get there but I was there
and I remember it was like he's either
played a really nice guy or a dog
yeah
wow wow okay I feel so um satisfied
right now like that was great so okay oh
I could not pinpoint that it was
bothering me too you made me watch it
and it is a newspaper Gray
he was a dick in the Evil movie
with the newspaper with the newspaper
is like one of the last things you would
think of when it comes to Tucker the
newspaper that's all I can remember
billion other iconic moments I don't
know I can remember all you can pull is
the newspaper you couldn't even pull him
I at least pulled newspaper oh geez this
is what happens to me where I can't
remember I remember weird moments in
movies I just I've always been like
there's that weird one line or moment
that for some reason stuck with me I
just remember him presenting the
newspaper and US knowing like his
parents were the dad was the one that
was the murderer yeah that's all I
forgot about that that's the newspaper
the newspaper tells us yeah okay that's
how I knew him that's how you know you
had questions about the the sister right
yeah yeah okay so let's Chit Chat check
the chicken out check it she was
um named Julie so she should be okay
Amanda Crew is her name no I did no I
was thinking she was Shannon's daughter
she was in sex drive she was in The
Haunting she was in age of Adeline
yep never seen any of those
all right all right good talk that
answers that
um I still feel the first movie had the
best
Ensemble overall but I prefer the the
lead characters here if that makes sense
like you isolate the lead characters in
the relationship and how that all formed
I I was more connected to that the first
movie and and I I bought more of the
drama this time around whereas like I
was finding myself taking some of the
drama series I was taking the drama
seriously and some of the conversation
scene seriously whereas in the first and
second movie they're kind of like cheesy
fun instead of me actually taking them
serious
what I thought this movie was actually
missing a little bit of though
was it it did kind of lose some fun uh
and not not I was never bored I was
never like not entertained but it did
take itself like really serious to the
point where I I could have used just a a
tiny like sprinkles of of some of that
energy from the second one I S I see
what you're saying but I didn't feel
that way I think that this kind of was a
perfect combination of one and two it's
probably my favorite one yeah it might
be mine too honestly because as I'm
talking I'm thinking about The Ensemble
I actually maybe preferred The Ensemble
most in this I thought that they were
really good chemistry here and it is a
little they're characters across the
franchise are very typical I I know that
the internet gets annoyed with me when I
say this but I'm just gonna do it anyway
because it's what I think a lot of times
like Angry woman or like dumb bimbo or
whatever even with like
um the black guy who doesn't believe
what's happening and like they it seems
like they have their archetypes and they
kind of stick to it movie after movie
which
um I think hopefully in the fourth and
fifth one we hear the fourth one's on
third grade
hopefully they kind of like shake that
up because I would love to see not the
like boyfriend who is the nice one in
the world and the girlfriend who's super
angry all the time whatever it is I feel
like we kind of are hitting the same
character types but the chemistry in
this one I really liked and the combo of
there are two main leads being
maybe two of the more recognizable like
in this movie
compared to the other ones they're very
good actors they did a really good job
in this
um yeah just I liked this I liked I like
the opening of this I like
um that they very quickly again know
they reference the other movie so they
know what's happening we don't have to
spend a whole hour figuring out like why
are we is everybody dying you know once
the franchise decided that they weren't
gonna do that I'm I think that was a
really smart choice
yeah I thought I think this one is not
as like the second one's more chaotic
like it it's a little bit more metal the
second one you know with the with the
lottery winner death the highway
sequence the dentist scene
that one actually is I think I think the
second one's more violent too yeah
definitely there was more Gore in that
one for sure yeah and this one it's it's
gory but it's definitely not as
exploitative Gore as I thought they
would go I thought like oh we're doing a
part three we're gonna go even crazier
Heaven's pretty gross you know what's
weird but the third but the second one's
like borderline and saw movie you know
with with the way some of those deaths I
feel like I I've liked them more
everyone then so I one I really liked
and two I liked it slightly more and
three I think is my favorite yeah that
doesn't happen often especially with a
horror franchise yeah that's cool that's
cool that's cool man that's cool Final
Destination y'all did it I can't believe
that you got Highway to Hell and I got
roller coaster in love what's the let's
see the thumbnail of the
what is
the death if you have to pick one death
from this that stands out to you what is
it from not the franchise from this
movie
uh hold on which one's the fourth one
is it remember they called it the five
oh god
oh that gives me nothing on this poster
oh I don't want to find out well glass
maybe yeah but it could just be like a
generic it would be Heart of Glass
yeah that's actually not a bad call
let's see what's the depth that stands
out to you the death that stood out to
me the most here
I mean the one I'll probably remember
the most is the is the tanning booth one
that's the one that stands out to me the
most too but that's the one where they
was they were really drawing like
everyone else's death correct me if I'm
wrong but everyone else's death is like
domino effect on effect they're dead
whereas that one was like suffering you
know and I think that's that's what the
second one now why I say that's
borderline saw is because there's there
was a lot more suffrage that was
happening with characters you know yeah
and and this one didn't really do that
it was kind of like watch DEATH do
domino effect what'd you call it what
was the thing you said Rube Goldberg Rue
Goldberg yeah there's Guru Goldberg and
then and then they just die and there's
some like disturbing imagery but I do
think the the characters yeah they have
like the ones that are super like the
two girls in the tanning booth are like
Beyond stereotypical uh the the but
they're still fun they're fun characters
especially for the time period it was
very common like that and definitely I
thought it was yeah they were it didn't
bother me it was just like okay we get
it and I believe the the who was it
mcclunky McKinley McKinley yeah McKinley
uh his his ponderings that he would
press I believed him like that he they
seemed like a it weirdly seemed like a
real character to me instead of let's
give this guy dialogue good to to
reflect some of the themes of the movie
you know it actually seemed like yeah I
believed this guy I felt that way too
especially when he's like you know death
is what happens when the energy is the
way like all the stuff I was like oh I
knew so many of you in high school there
you guys were like a whole group of
um pretentious
yeah whatever that was but yeah I
thought that was really good yeah got
those really effing good this franchise
is so solid what a bummer that we hear
the fourth one isn't great I'm excited
to see it anyway because I'm sure there
are good moments but like what if we
walk away Santa
for like
then death might come get us honestly
they're like no you don't deserve it uh
but so far this I mean this whole
franchise is excellent it's been really
fun and I feel like this is the one we
took the most serious like I feel like
we kind of take the piss out of them a
little bit more but this one we were
like I'm taking this seriously which is
a good sign actually who is your
favorite character in this in this one
yeah
um
I really like Mary I mean I I felt like
Mary Elizabeth Winsted actually had an
arc because she's very timid and she's
closed off and then by the end she's got
like a set of friends now and she seems
like she's you could see physically her
transformation that she has grown into
someone more confident and that she has
gone through the grieving process even
before she dies yeah before she dies her
death is like go [__] yourself which I
really loved I love the way how they do
kill off everyone in the end but I guess
there's just no way to really def I
don't I still don't get how can someone
clarify that for me if you made it this
far how did the characters in the second
one defeat death but these guys didn't
I'm Gonna Keep looping back and looping
back but that didn't happen with the
characters in the second one it did
they no it's remember moved on to the
little boy then I don't think he moved
on to him I think it's hitting them
simultaneously I I'm assuming they're
gonna looping back to them and the same
with the characters in the first one the
little boy had nothing to do what do you
think death is because there's death
I feel like there's got to be like
multiple Reapers because you know people
are 150 000 people are dying every day
like they said here at least in this
world of Final Destination 150 000
people die every day so there's got to
be like one Reaper's assignment per case
on something like this who's just has to
you know what I mean because that's more
of like a god scenario where they're
overseeing a lot at once you think
there's one Reaper who's seen it all
right I don't think it's a Reaper I
think death death is like Oh you mean
like an omnipresence yeah okay and in
the order and there's like clusters okay
yeah I imagine they're kind of like a
citadel of like death employees and like
someone's trying to make a good
impression so in the first one none of
them are still left anymore because the
only Survivor the two survivors we found
out one of them died and yeah one of
them moved on to the next one yeah and
the next one
the two people lived right yes and then
this one we're assuming she got smushed
by the train oh they all died yeah for
sure so I wonder if we're gonna get any
of the two from two and four or five
maybe maybe David's Devin saw what
actually is alive I feel like they
should I keep telling you that's really
how I kept it I mean you got a lot right
this time so I'm gonna lead I'm gonna go
with the fact that I think you might be
right but I could be wrong I do love the
ending here of how she has the
premonition again and death is just like
go to hell because we think the way that
the premonition works this time I'm like
oh they killed them all and then I'm
like oh they didn't so I think we're in
the clear I think we're gonna stop it
and then they're like ah sucker I I look
I think the second movie's Highway
sequence is masterfully executed I do I
think though but that one is just so
crazy this one felt like
this could really happen like that what
happens here on the roller coaster that
is a fear of mine and you know you've
seen news reports where yeah they are
just stuck upside down and like it's
happened to people and and some terrible
tragedies have happened on roller
coasters before yes on planes and
highways as well but there was something
about this one that other than like he
happens to grab the dude when he's you
know grabs the I forget the black Jock's
name whatever his name is
um he grabs that guy other than that
everything else was like this seems very
real and there was such a tension to it
like the the highway one was like crazy
and fun this one was like this is truly
scary what's happening right now that
was actually like the highway one wasn't
scary to me the highway one was really
fun this one was I am I am literally
like scared of what's happening the
reason I think I liked this opening the
best is because we see car accidents in
movies all the time even though this was
on a grander scale and we do a lot on
the road like even with yeah yeah sure
you know just franchise movies just even
this year right there's like a lot of
car chases a lot of car accidents just
so much car stuff same thing with plane
crashes we do see a decent amount of it
even with like lost and yellow jackets
and um of course in movies too or like
you think the plane's going down I can't
recall
seeing in a movie a big roller coaster
accident yeah and I think that's re I
think the roller coaster to make Mary
Elizabeth Winstead's character so much
about uh someone who has this fear and
this sense of this need to control when
you put them in a situation where you
have no control like there's some
semblance of you can at least move
around on a plane yeah but on a roller
coaster you are locked in and trapped in
a situation like that so I love the
thematically to line up her character
with that as well I just think this
one's shot the best too I think out of
all three of them this one looks the
best of them it felt like it had a
bigger yeah yeah like cinematography I
wonder if it was the same
cinematographer actually or if they went
with somebody new well James Wong
directed the first one and then he came
back for this one so they use the same
person that they previously I feel like
he refined his work
um but no overall man I thought I think
this is a this is a really I really like
this one a lot I was I was really
impressed with this one what's your
ranking
I think right now I would have to go
it's impossible to beat the freshness of
the first one right it's impossible to
beat that oh it's Robert McLaughlin who
did Game of Thrones Lovecraft this one
um the cinematographer oh wow did a few
episodes of Ray Donovan he's done a lot
of the shows that we like he did 1923
oh damn he did 1923 yeah
um that's yeah he's DP'd a lot of
um Great West world oh sweet interesting
interesting
okay
sorry you were in the middle of talking
when I interrupted you to do that oh you
interrupted me with important
information but the facts nothing but
the
facts but we got to get you out of here
yeah because you got to go to your your
ground all right so then let's give a
special shout out well I mean we should
wrap up all right a little bit more too
you know okay well
all right let me say the stuff leave a
like comment make sure you're subscribed
be here for our next one hopefully if
you guys like this video we continue
watching the franchise
um and make sure that you make it safely
to your final destination
of Heaven one day not today hopefully a
long time from now
okay bye
in the shadow and it's oh yeah and a
shout out what's going on to who I think
we should do
uh Daniel Gallagher but I liked what you
did before where you did this Boston
acronym thing oh okay cool so I think
you should actually give it a nurse who
Daniel gallacher sounds like an Irish
guy from Boston [__] Daniel Gallagher
dude all right Daniel here what do we
got D is for
uh D is for Duncan donkeys you got
America runs on Duncan you know A is for
Angels in the Outfield which is baseball
which Red Socks we got there n is for
Newton it's where I'm from I did that
last time but you know sometimes you
just got to go back to it I is for Icy
it's so cold there in the winter it's
just ice on the ground you got to make
sure you have your salt to put it on the
ice e is for England
comma new because it's in New England
because that's where Boston is and the L
is for let's [__] go
Daniel Gallagher there we go thanks for
being a patron honestly
um you are the sexiest of the rejects
and that's the title that you've earned
today
how'd we do uh I think there was no we
it was all you thank you
oh good okay uh we'll see you guys next
time for Final Destination four yeah
might as well might as well find out how
terrible it is I'm nervous about that
one I think we already have the lowest
expectations yeah so it could be good
it's a means to an end the fifth one's
supposed to be good okay yeah so fifth
one some people say it's the best and
we'll cover that in like four weeks when
you're back from Boston yeah
sorry okay bye
foreign